die geschwister können vom etwas schwein
als du wirklich ein dummkopf geboren
hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video auf dem kanal meine damen und
herren jetzt es bereits im titel
eingeblendet diese serie ist schlimmer
als hilf mir es dreht sich nämlich heute
mal wieder um krass schule
das ist die schule hinter den gittern
sieht echt bisschen aus wie im knast
heute die wäre quatsch oder nicht kennen
solltet habt ihr wahrscheinlich erst mal
30.000 gehirnzellen mehr als jeder der
sie kennt gras schule ist eine serie die
auf rtl2 läuft und es geht in dieser
serie um junge lehrer die an einer
hauptschule in köln unterrichten und die
schüler sind ja die haben einige
probleme und sind auch ein bisschen dumm
die folge die wir uns heute anschauen
werden heißt krass schule schlägerei auf
dem pausenhof
das hat sich wieder richtig viel
versprechen dann bevor wir uns
allerdings direkt in die folge und damit
auch in die reaction stürzen würde ich
sagen schauen wir uns erst mal einige
kommentare unter dem video an alter rtl2
so krass ossi ihr könnt alle einpacken
nach zehn sekunden denke ich nur so jung
so stelle ich mir die hauptschule vorn
kämpfen wie muschis schauspielkunst
aller hollywood jetzt mal ernsthaft er
schaut sich das freiwillig an ok nein
danke zurück zu netflix und da fragt man
sich warum die deutsche schauspielkunst
international keinen anklang findet die
lehrerin ist einfach stärker als die
anderen boards für arschlöcher ja
da wird wieder geistiger dünnschiss
verbreitet ich würde allerdings sagen
wir fangen direkt mal an mit der folge
hier wir sehen schon die beiden leute
stehen auf dem pausenhof denen hier
kennen wir schon aus der letzten folge
das ist der lukas den anderen kenne ich
jetzt nicht die beiden wollen sich wohl
gerade prügeln denke ich mal
[Applaus]
gab es solche situationen damals bei
euch wirklich auf dem pausenhof das wird
in serien filmen die zeichentrick
cartoons jeden was immer so dargestellt
als wenn das dann so voll die attraktion
wäre
und hier läuft sogar noch so ein mädel
lang mit seinem schild von wegen runde
eins
sie nähern sich gleich gehts los freude
die shops die sich schon ein bisschen
weg fassen sich schon an alle anderen
rufen den fuji umarmen sich also bisher
ist das noch keine schläge reise
wirklich die schützen sich nur ein
bisschen weg das sieht bisher eigentlich
eher aus als wäre das irgendwie
sportunterricht jetzt kommt das ist also
das war wirklich die heftigste kreide
ich hier gesehen habe
es ist soll jetzt nicht so klingen als
willig wir wollen dass die sich gerade
auf die fresse schlagen so die kann
machen was sie wollen aber wenn im titel
steht schlägerei denke ich mir dass sie
irgendwie so aufeinander losgehen
stattdessen ist sowas passiert und es
sind einfach nur missglückte umarmungen
die lehrerin geht jetzt auf jeden fall
dazwischen oder habt ihr das gesehen
die lehrerin kommt und jetzt schmeißt
sie leben ja weg die lehrerin dann
einfach mehr schlägerei betriebe als die
schüler einfach umschreiben gar kein
würden ersten stufe rechnet man die
wollten sich umarmen und dann halt böse
dabei aus
und du kannst du dich für das nachspiel
haben warum wird es für lukas ein
nachspiel haben aber nicht für diese
andere person mit einer anzulegen das
ist ben und ben es anscheinend neu an
dieser aaseeschule ich habe mich ein
bisschen informiert und es ist wirklich
so dass die folgen mehr oder weniger
aufeinander aufbauen und das ist
natürlich ein mega gut dass sich jetzt
bei meiner ersten kreisschule reaktionen
auf folge 16 reagiert habe und jetzt bin
ich bei folge nummer 9 angekommen aber
ich meine so gucke ich auch immer bei
netflix der schuldig mich die ganze zeit
sein handy geklaut zu haben
ok
handy von lukas weg und lukas denkt dass
der martin das hat ja vielleicht heißt
doch bitte nicht im dumm wenn ich jetzt
den rucksack nachsehen was finde ich
gegangen bin ich in thun die u8 hat das
handy wirklich geklaut
lol okay das hätte ich nicht vermutet
morgen heimlich zurück liegst dann habe
ich hier nichts gesehen nichts gehört
okay ich weiß nicht was ich für eine
lehrerin ist aber ich würd schüler nicht
beibringen dass wenn man was klaut man
das einfach heimlich zurück gibt
der kampf war schon krass ja das war
echt also connor mcgregor kann da
einpacken
maria hat doch nicht eine sekunde daran
gedacht dass lukas bei dem kampf
irgendetwas hätte passieren können oder
maria das aus findet dann macht ihr
nicht kenne ich das kriegst du dort ja
ich weiß ich weiß man hier ist meine
beste freundin und man kann seine
freunde noch richtig freuen ausspannen
und ok jetzt natürlich richtig dumm dass
wir uns sofort angucken die sieben
folgen von meiner reck der letzten
session spielt
ich hoffe mal die hat meine kraft schule
reaktion von letzter woche gesehen denn
dort war es so dass der lukas mit der
maria nicht mehr zusammen ist sondern
jetzt mit mit der hier vorne die rechts
sitzt irgendwie doch in dieser folge
jetzt gerade ist es irgendwie so dass
sie hier
geradezu gibt dass sie auf lukas stetig
steigt dann nicht mehr durch lukas und
ben kann sich eben mehr gebrüllt wenn
ich dazwischen gang
die haben sich nicht geprügelt ich bin
mir sicher dass die bands mutter etwas
erreichen können der junge muss noch
unbedingt gefördert werden
mit seiner lese und rechtschreibschwäche
umgehen kann ok
das heißt wenn es arm und hat eine lese
und rechtschreibschwäche und ist jetzt
neu an der schule
der tut mir echt ein bisschen leid also
die sind jetzt hier bei den bändern
scheint zu hause in köln angekommen sie
läuft erstmal gegen den tank und sie
gehen um das die mutter der streit um
die stellen sich vorher werden sie beim
sek guten tag mein name das ist immer
eine kollegin amy sideboard verdammte
lehrer an einer fiktiven hauptschule und
wir sind lehrer ihres sohnes wenn ich
bin jetzt gerade ziemlich knapp ich muss
jetzt rechter tanke verzichten anders
machen wirklich kurz reinkommen ist echt
wichtig auch kurz danke schön
okay sie machen fortschritte und kommen
schon mal die wohnung rein gemacht
bringen die kinder um sie mit
zähneputzen danach nichts süßes mehr und
sind auch wieder auf dem boden gepresst
also mach das auch wenn hier nichts wie
ein pavian käfig
also ich hab ja wirklich schon einige
male auf hilfen reagiert aber da hat
noch nie jemand wirklich auf dem boden
geblieben ich muss jetzt so tanke hier
spiele ich mal den boden sauber sicher
da wieder hin gebildet alter schwede was
das denn für den haushalt wie weit
dieses treiben wird auf der sonderschule
landen oder was du bist einfach nur faul
das ist doch kein problem denn tut mir
richtig leid wirklich jugendlichen
dummkopf geboren hab ich dem kopf
geboren der name hat er nur drei
buchstaben [ __ ] ich glaube da wäre es
gut wenn der lukas auch mal die mutter
verprügelt ja obwohl es gibt es
eigentlich verzichten ein baby freuen
sie nutzt den sohn einfach nur als
babysitter ich habe drei jobs davon habe
ich kein verlieren weil der vater kaum
unterhalt zahlt dann habe ich noch drei
kinder tiere omas und ich muss zur
arbeit
tiere
einfach mal ganz viele tiere doch im
haushalt haben oder sie meinen die die
einfach mal überall hinpassen ist tun
sie ein bisschen gefallen melden sich
wenn sie beruhigt haben
sie ist gar nicht mal hässlich also auch
nicht schön aber von allen die mit
spielen ist sie die am wenigsten
hässliche und sie ist definitiv auch
viel hübscher als die sexbombe aus
meiner letzten reaktion
hör auf deine zu wissen ich bin so
wütend
warte mal
mir fällt jetzt setzt auf dass dieses in
die anscheinend die katze ist ich dachte
die ganze zeit dass wäre irgendeine
tochter von der die da einfach überall
hin ist aber jetzt hat sie die katze der
eigene blende und meinte dann halt
einfach so passend gefährdet die gesamte
zukunft ihres sohnes deswegen hab ich
bewusst ich nicht zum letzten mal
gesehen ja ich kann nur hoffen dass frau
reißt dich jetzt zusammen heißt und
ihrem sohn nicht noch mehr vorwürfe
ich bin stark wie sie so richtig
ausrastet mich nicht zum letzten mal
gesehen und dann ihr kollege neben ihm
so völlig locker sprangen hoffen dass
freiräume hast dich jetzt zusammen heißt
und ihrem sohn nicht noch mehr vor wird
das erbgut ab und böser bulle war hat
glaube ich kann man die ist echt eine
gute schauspielerin oder das ist köln
das ist auch köln das ist
barbarossaplatz ja ok für die auch in
köln gespielt ich vollidiot also ich
glaube in den nächsten szenen hier vorne
wird jetzt nur noch irgendwie eine story
zwischen den beiden erzählt da uns ja
nicht weiter interessiert würde ich
sagen
an der stelle würde ich meine reaction
hier auf die kreisschule schlägerei
folgen jetzt auch band meine damen und
herren ich hab mir letzte woche das
erste mal auf das unglück reagiert und
da dachte ich mir wirklich das ist ja
echt nicht nicht so also wie hilf mir
doch diese folge hat mir gezeigt doch es
ist auch schon echt asien besten wenn
euch meine reaktion hierauf diese folge
gefallen hat dann das gerne einen daumen
hoch da wenn ihr wollt dass ich in ein
paar tagen noch mal auf eine andere
folge reagiere die ihr mir jetzt unten
in die kommentare schreiben könnt also
schreibt mir gerne andere folge krass
schule und in die kommentare
und dann werde ich darauf reagieren
[Musik]
ein